Donald Trump responsable de abuso sexual
y difamación este fue El veredicto del
Jurado en la corte Federal de Manhattan
sobre el juicio iniciado por la
escritora y Jim Carroll que acusa al
expresidente de violarla en una tienda
departamental en Nueva York que en los
90s al ser un juicio civil la libertad
de Trump no estaba en juego pero la
corte le concedió a la escritora una
indemnización por 5 millones de dólares
por daños y prejuicios el alegato de
violación fue rechazado por la corte sin
embargo el equipo legal de Trump expresó
que están listos para apelar la decisión
fue un veredicto extraño esta fue una
demanda por violación fue un caso de
violación todo el tiempo y el Jurado
rechazó eso pero hizo otras conclusiones
Así que obviamente apelaremos esas otras
conclusiones
no se presentó a las audiencias del
juicio y a través de su perfil en la red
social de la cual es dueño rechazó la
decisión Del Jurado
No tengo idea de quién es esta mujer
este veredicto es una desgracia Es la
continuación de la cacería de brujas más
grande de la historia la escritora
dedicó su Victoria a todas aquellas que
han sufrido porque no les creyeron a
pesar del veredicto y de enfrentar otras
causas legales Donald Trump se mantiene
como líder en las encuestas para
convertirse en el nominado del partido
de republicano lo que le permitiría
aspirar nuevamente a la presidencia en